كله تلك الالام والصرخات لم تهز لهم جفنا
لم يكتفوا بمجرد مراقبه من مات ومن يعاني
تحت الانقاض بل سولت لهم انفسهم ما هو
ابشع من ذلك بكثير
انهم لصوص الازمات وتجارها الراقصون على
جثث الضحايا كارثه الزلزال في كل من تركيا
وسوريا كانت مهوله لكن الكثير ممن فارقوا
الحياه تحت الركام لم يموتوا بسببها بل
قتلوا بحسب ما يصف اهالي الضحايا قتلوا
نتيجه جشع مقاول استهان بارواح الناس فضل
زياده ارباحه على الالتزام بالحد الادنى
للمواصفات اللازمه في البناء فكانت
النتيجه بناء هشا امام الزلزال وقاتلا لمن
يقطنون فيه السلطات التركيه القت القبض
على اكثر من 130 مقاولا كان بعضهم يهم
بالهرب خارج البلاد
وتعهدت باجراء تحقيق شامل مع اي شخص يشتبه
في مسؤوليته عن انهيار المباني في الزلزال
تم التحديد 131 مشتبها به حتى الان على
انهم مسؤولون عن انهيار المباني في
المحافظات العشر التي تضررت من الهزات
التي وقعت يوم الاثنين الماضي السادس من
فبراير
المقاولون المحتالون ليسوا اسوا من هؤلاء
ففيما تنتشر رائحه الموت في كل مكان
استغلوا هول الصدمه وحاله الارتباك بين
الاهالي ليتسللوا الى المنازل والمحال
التي هجرها اهلها على عجاله وينهب ما فيها
الشرطه التركيه القت القبض على بعضهم فيما
تحركت الحكومه هناك لاستعاده وفرض القانون
متجرنا في حاله خراب
صابونه واللصوص نهبوها لقد اخذوا ما في
وسعهم وتركوا ما تركوه وراءهم عمليات
النهب في كل مكان
في ذلك السوق عبر الشارع
المساعدات والاعانات لم تسلم ايضا من
السرقه كم هائل من المساعدات العينيه تمت
سرقته
والمحتالون تعدوا المناطق المنهوبه
ليستغلوا تعاطف الناس حول العالم وينشر
روابط وهميه تدعو الى التبرع ضمن الحملات
الالكترونيه الجاريه حاليا خلال الايام
الماضيه انتشرت عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي قوائم بحسابات بنكيه وارقام
هواتف في بلدان مختلفه تحث على التبرع من
خلالها لضحايا زلزال من دون التاكد من
موثوقيه تلك الحسابات او الى اين تذهب
كارثه الزلزال اثار التعاطف الملايين من
اصحاب الضمير الحي حول العالم لكن يبدو ان
اللص او المحتال لا يابه باي ظرف انساني
بل العكس يستغله لمصلحته الشخصيه غير ابه
بارواح تزهق وانفس تشرد